In information theory, there's a standard measurement
called "mutual information,"
for how many bits of info travel from source to destination.
If a monkey hears another monkey's call,
let's say that's 1 bit.
So a monkey sees an eagle and calls to its friend.
The friend hears the call. Presumably, it hides.
But what if the second monkey hears the "snake" alert,
instead of eagle?
The message is still 1 bit, but its meaning has been transformed.
Mutual information measures don't distinguish between
these two messages, even though they have very different meanings.
In their new paper, information theorists Artemy Kolchinsky & Bernat Corominas-Murtra
present a new way to think about this that distinguishes between copied information
and transformed information.
This distinction between copied and transformed information
arises in our computers,
when we either copy files or encrypt them.
It also arises in biology, where DNA is both replicated
and transcribed.
And of course, in animal communication.
According to the authors, modeling these different types of information
might help us better understand these processes,
to the benefit of monkeys everywhere.